est-ce quizy by kenzo ont des enfants
norman un enfant mxm aussi et toi c'est
quand olala mais attendez écoutez je
reçois un nombre de messages
incalculable de gens qui me disent et
squeeze accord l'enfant toi aussi
mais egée que 23 ans ça se fait pas ce
que vous me faites vous mettez une
pression énorme sur un truc qui doit me
pendre au nez dans au moins sept ans
selon moi allez plutôt dire ça à cyprien
qui à 30 ans ou à nate qui en a 34 ou
même à pierre cros qui à 32 ans mais moi
laissez moi tranquille
pourquoi je peux après avoir un enfant
des amis déjà parce que je trouve qu'ils
sont démoniaques
ce sont des entités démoniaques je
redoute les enfants j'ai peur des
enfants ok ça peut être les êtres les
plus mignons et cool tout comme des
êtres fourbe et pervers qui sont prêts à
tout pour avoir ce qu'ils volent j'ai
beaucoup de mal avec les enfants en
général c'est même pas genre moi avoir
un enfant c'est chaud c'est les enfants
en général j'ai du mal parce que je suis
pas prêt à faire des concessions à
accepter des choses à m'infliger du mal
le projet je vous rencontre j'ai une
vision très triste 2 a pour le moment
mais je suis jeune [ __ ] c'est normal
donc j'ai mis au point un petit est ok
nous allons aujourd'hui regarder des
vidéos d'enfants sur un peu glauque du
comme ça oui
ne vous en faites pas des vidéos
d'enfants normal normaux enfants normaux
donc déjà qu'on ne s'est pas accordé
normal c'est que ce n'est pas le moment
d'avoir un enfant dans sa vie qui font
des petites actions qu'on a nous mêmes
fut aussi quand on avait leur âge mais
si vous êtes en âge d'avoir un enfant
vous supporterez la vue de ses actions
ce qui est rarement mon cas mais bon
d'après-vous et à col enfants squeeze
allez on enfile ce casque et on s'y
colle ça me met mal je le sais d'avancé
toute sa vie il aura de la haine dans
son coeur à cause de ce moment à cause
d'un autre enfant évidemment non
[Musique]
si ma fille fait ça mais qu'est ce que
je fais au cachot occasion tout de suite
comment vous faites pour cautionner ça
ou pour lui dire c'est pas bien ou pour
mettre un pansement sur la plaie que ça
aura créé dans le coeur de ce jeune
homme de quoi il est fait ce pansement
ah non non ils n'ont
[Musique]
alors déjà j'ai vraiment cru qu'il
allait frapper son enfant c'est horrible
pourquoi parce qu'à sa place je ne
serais pas resté si calme même si un
objet tombe sur le bouton on off de mon
pc je vais m'énerver contre l'objet je
vais le casser vous voyez là on vient de
voir vraiment le pourquoi je ne veux pas
d'enfant s'il fallait montrer une vidéo
c'est celle là c'est vraiment celle la
seule fois où quelqu'un et à mon pc
pendant que j'y jouais je me suis fait
20 points de suture à la main après il
ya un petit côté mignon genre il veut
l'attention de son père et l'a compris
qu il faisait ça ils l'avaient est-ce
que ce père passe beaucoup trop de temps
devant les jeux vidéo d'ailleurs il a
perdu son travail
entre temps et n'arrivent plus à
subvenir aux besoins de sa famille donc
voilà c'est une manière pour son fils
déjà très intelligent de lui faire
comprendre et aux saisies toi papa c'est
très beau est ce que je me fais des
films peut-être mon frère a pris mon
casse et les a remis comme si rien
n'était ça l'est vraiment moi plus
jeunes comme moi elle sait qu il peut
savoir que le petit frère a pris les
écouteurs
elle y la casse est assez horrible
comment il peut se dire ça parce c'était
pas moi il a pété à deux endroits
il a rafistolé un endroit sur deux il
n'était pas loin du perfect ça aurait pu
passer s'ils avaient pensé au deuxième
c'est génial c'est pourquoi j'ai une
anecdote de moi qui a fait exactement la
même chose est en plus jeunes mais
exactions vareilles jeu joué à quake sur
le pc portable de mon père et je jouais
tout et je faisais que de perdre que de
me faire défoncer que de perdre comme un
non en fait et là j'ai frappé comme ça
là sur le clavier du pc portable parce
que j'ai rager et mais qu'il ya une
touche qui est parti c'est bon mais qui
est vraiment partie par la fenêtre comme
ça avec ses petites jambes est parti
elle a dit j'arrête je souffrais
exactement comme cet enfant qu'est ce
que j'ai fait j'ai pris la touche gelé
remis j'ai fermé l'ordi et je les range
est comme ça tout en sachant que cet
ordinateur portable est l outil de
travail de mon père qu'est ce qui s'est
passé le lendemain
moi j'ai été réveillé très tôt par mon
père très très tôt mon petit cousin
badass a commandé 300 $ de jouer sans
que mme atteinte et que mon oncle sache
voici une photo du moment où tout le
monde s'est rendu compte du truc
regardez regardez à les diaboliques
regardez je vais mettre cette vidéo dans
la catégorie serait d'horreur je déconne
pas alors c'est ça être riche
voilà ce qu elle se dit sous le regard
du livreur qui lui ne comprend rien mais
nous on se prenait pour des délinquants
quand volé le téléphone de nos parents
pour faire des codes allopass là pour
sur des kamas sur dofus mec rien la
nouvelle génération la nouvelle
génération mais qu'ils ont franchi un
cap ils ont innové comme personne avant
au [ __ ] on est dans un shonen vous
sentez là vous sentez ce qui va se
passer est bien plus puissant que moi et
il le sait mais je vais grandir
je vais me dépasser et je me vengerai
vous voyez là par exemple comment tu
peux bien y'a pas de soucis quand tes
parents je trouve que tu acceptes des
trucs mais qui pour moi sont choquants à
l'heure actuelle mois le gamin camille
gratos la balle dans la tête je vais je
lui court après déjà la trappe comme ça
par les aisselles et je lui dis pourquoi
t'as fait ça
qu'est ce qui t'a pris plus jamais tu
m'entends plus jamais ça
pas bon dans une démarche bienveillante
et sage bien entendu
oh la vache sauter sur la mercedes de
son papa quel plaisir mais il veut péter
la voiture pour se venger ou ils
comptent vraiment sur le capot pour
l'aider à à sauter plus haut comme un
trampoline je veux comprendre et des
mois à comprendre à percer le mystère de
l'enfance cet enfant a besoin d'être
supervisé face à un mariage
j'espère que la guerre ce n'est pas
énorme il en a rien à ces incroyables
mais c'est touchant y'a pas de graves
répercussions ces innocents il a vu un
gros paquet de tissus et c'est dire je
vais sauter dedans ça va amortir la
chute c'est trop cool c'est mignon oh la
la qu'est ce qui se passe là ça veut pas
dire je suis prêt à avoir un enfant
rassurez moi un enfant frappe au visage
chaque parent dont chaque qui est un
homme de 2 m 16 et qui pèse 147 kg
équipe unique et à n'importe quel moment
ta mère autant vous dire que cet enfant
n'a peur de rien ce regard ça ne l'a pas
du tout fait rire et ne peut pas grondé
le petit garçon car il est sur un
plateau télé et ça peut être mal vu car
ce n'est pas son petit garçon qu'elle
belle situation de merde [ __ ] je là je
m'enterre si c'est mon gosse je
m'enterre c'est la honte c'est horrible
je crois que je suis trop sensible au
regard que les jambes porteront au
jugement en fait qu'ils auront deux mois
par rapport à comment se comportent mon
gas plus tard c'est je trouve ça doit
être un truc très stressant quand et par
enterrements ont peur qu'il fasse honte
qui se comporte pas correctement et du
coup ça envoie le message aux gens du
bâlois y fait ça donc je m'en occupe pas
comme il faut et mon éducation départ
bol je pense moi je me ferais matrix et
par ce truc là je serai un fou je
deviendrais fou il a essayé de sauter au
dessus d'une flaque d'eau tout en tenant
maman je ne comprends pas ce titre
aucune copie cité entre cette personne
et ses enfants je suis horrible de dire
ça en tout cas y est on est face à un
gros moment d'incompréhension soyons
clairs au nom elle s'est vraiment
ramasse au la peau et qu'est ce qui faut
il bien le langueux l'équipe russe avec
son bras ils l'accusent d'être
responsable je comprends pas je n'ai
rien compris à cette vidéo l m'a rendu
anxieux la suivante s'il vous plaît
annoncé la même mécanique la preuve en
vidéo
celle qui fait mal celle où tu regrettes
immédiatement d'ailleurs fait un enfant
en arrive à ce soir il va tout il va
tout péter
ce père qui avait consacré probablement
deux heures de son temps à mettre au
point le parcours parfait de dominos et
qui comptait donner le plaisir du
déclenchement de ce dernier à sa fille
pour la combler de bonheur et de joie
[Musique]
nombre de choses qui ne vont pas avec
déjà est ce que c'est moi où est ce que
cette arme est cette fois trop
puissantes par rapport à l'âge de ces
gamins mais qu'ils ont un [ __ ] de
gonna be automatique à l'air de tiris
super forme et il tire sur la caméra les
vidéos je me souviens à l'époque j'avais
acheté moi j'étais très très fan de
degen habits à l'époque les gens
n'avaient acheté 1 15 euro dans un truc
flinguer un peu en cachette genre il est
sorti un endroit bizarre du magasin ya
vraiment une sorte de trafic cacher mais
c'était un bolt ça veut dire qu'il
fallait faire crac-crac avant de tirer
crac crac
je suis une personne âgée ok c'est bon
j'ai l'âge d'avoir un enfant c'est bon
il faut informer aux accords d'ici
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il fait oh c'est quoi cet
adulte un peu bête dans un corps
d'enfant biologique ni la personne qui
filme et qu'il l'est où ça se passait
sous ses yeux ni son comportement à lui
ou alors c'est très logique pour lui et
moi en tant qu'adulte je ne comprends
pas ce qu'il est en train de manigancer
tracé sûrement ça d'ailleurs le [ __ ]
c'est vraiment mal comme le truc c'est
touchant et naïve je trouve le fait
qu'entre des tout petits tas seule
défense s'est enfoncé dans le mensonge à
tout prix même s'il ya toutes les
preuves que tu as fait cette bêtise tu
ne veux surtout pas l'avouer et tu veux
totalement le cacher comme le petit cap
et et le casque de sa grande soeur tout
à l'heure c'est mizuho gfr nintendo a
voiliers wally vrai visage là on l'a vue
là c'est la fin de cette vidéo
foutez moi la paix pitié avec les
enfants je ne veux pas d'enfant pour le
moment et offrait une vidéo dans sept
ans quand j'en aurai un où je regarde
cette vidéo là où je me dis oh lala com
j'ai échangé aux jets ténue la bande
écoutez j'espère que cette vidéo vous
aura plu et vous aura servi de leçon
s'il vous plaît arrêtez de vous dire et
à quand l'enfant ça me met une pression
que je ne dois pas avoir à mon âge
arrêté par contre c'est que pour
beaucoup d'entre vous on a vraiment
grandi ensemble
et oui il y en a un qui regarde cette
vidéo qui avait 16 ans à l'époque quand
on a regardé mes vidéos quand j'avais
mois 17 ans et un jour j'aurai 30 et
vous aurez 31 et ce jour là on reviendra
tous regardé cette vidéo là croyez-moi
c'est ce qui va se passer en tout cas
bravo à tous les parents du monde qui
supporte les bêtises de leurs enfants et
qui le renvoie tout l'amour du monde et
qui leur offrent toutes les chances
possibles pour réussir dans la vie je
trouve ça très beau ça j'avoue je peux
être que touché par ça je trouve ça ouf
même quand je vois mcfly carlito l'amour
qu'ils envoient leurs enfants ça me
touche mais je ne veux pas que ça ne me
concerne pour le moment
ok la leçon est passé c'est pour vous
cette vidéo et personne d'autre c'est
vous la allez je vous laisse
veut pas d'enfant
je voulais pas d'enfants vos moments
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]